nathaniel's in raleigh north carolina hi
nathaniel how are you
hey dave uh thanks for taking my call um
absolutely i've gotten a lot of we our
family's gotten a lot of benefits out of
your uh baby steps so
thank you we're on babies up too way to
go um my
question is um we have been dependent on
our parents i'm married i have three
children but we've been to parent
dependent on our parents basically the
whole time we've been married about five
years
we've recently come into a larger sum of
money from the stimulus checks and
tax refunds stuff like that and we've
been trying to live
independently from them and paying off
our debts
now the question i'm wondering is should
i just take
all the money we have every dollar put
it on all our debt
and get help now or try to stave off
their help as long as possible and be
independent
with the high probability that in about
a year we're probably going to need to
ask for help again why do you need so
much help man what what is it about your
life that
you can't make it because you went from
help from mom and dad to then you went
from help
from the government right right what's
what's the problem
um so the main problem there's a couple
of things my wife
is chronically ill okay um she's got she
had a bot scoliosis surgery as a child
and has a lot of chronic pain so we
spend a lot of money
on physical therapists and
rehabilitation and trying to figure that
piece of the puzzle out okay and and so
that that takes up
a lot of the money and then it's been
some you know help and similar to that
she has some dietary issues that help
with her condition
with some because she has some muscle
elasticity and inflammation issues so
that runs up our bill a fair amount and
so
and also i think there's been a couple
improved career jumps that i had i had
from liberal arts degree to easy think
tank
to um corporate philanthropy to teacher
to now
accountant so that that too so trying to
figure that
out and i think i probably made more
jumps than i needed to so that's
that's why we've needed help in the past
so what do you make
i make about 57 000 a year okay
and what does your wife what do you
spend on your wife's medical care
um last month when we were doing our
budget this the first may was our first
budgeted month
um it was probably over 500
dollars and then we also had to pay for
frenectomy for
our infant our third child and that was
like 600
on top of that yeah but that's that's
only one time thing your wife says more
your wife is more yeah
your wife's situation is more chronic
and so yeah and the
uh food situation for your wife costs an
extra how much
i'd say we spend about we spent close to
2500
on groceries this month
that's that's ex that's an extraordinary
amount of money
and you're talking to a guy that is so
obnoxious about what i put in my body
we we overspend at our house and you
have almost tripled what i spend
right obnoxious to the point that my
wife rolls her eyes at me
right something isn't clicking here
so you so you're just saying i need to
reduce the food bill i mean
and that's what we're doing right now
with i mean we're trying to do the
budget and making sure that that's true
yeah i think there's a lot
listen number one neither one of us
are uh saying that we don't that
we would we would not suggest that you
don't take good care of your wife
right ever okay um
however sometimes when you're dealing
with chronic pain and chronic issues
the emotions around that can sometimes
justify
a different level of stupidity
and that's what we're calling out
right so i mean 500 bucks a month
did not scare me on medical that's six
thousand dollars a year
you've got a chronic situation that's
very possible
okay i can that one i can i can chew on
and
making fifty seven thousand dollars a
year plus picking up some ot here or
there or doing some other stuff
doing some tax returns or something if
you're an accountant to pick up some
extra money you you can we can handle
that with three kids
you can make progress and live on sixty
thousand dollars a year
and without your parents helping without
the government's help
okay now the 2500 food bill though
something's really screwed up there
you're going to fix that
and still figure out a way to feed her
food that does not cause her issues
okay so it's really about just attacking
things so i guess the other question is
like
to that point is should it really just
be really try not to get help from my
parents
i think it's really really curious that
you're getting help from your parents if
you make 60 000
a year and have three kids okay and
i want you to flip the question how much
debt do you have
uh well so i have about fifty six
thousand dollars in student debt we paid
off a credit card with the money that we
got
um and then but now i've been thinking
about it my
wife has a loan that her parents said
they would pay but it's in her name
that i do not know the amount of that
i'm guessing is about twenty thousand
dollars
how much you know in your cars uh
nothing
nothing we our cars have been guests
okay any other big debt you're leaving
out of this discussion so far
no we're on we're we're renting right
now but we're renting
more in a more expensive place so much
i would like 1900 a little rich okay
so let me tell you what's running
through my head i'll just share openly
and this is how i'm kind of making some
of these judgment calls and then you can
go make them because you're obviously a
sharp guy
okay you have three kids and you make
almost exactly the average household
income in america
and the average household in america has
2.5 kids so i mean you are like average
average average
average money-wise okay and so you ought
to be able to live on that
that's what's running through my head
now you mix in there you got some debt
and you which most people do
and we're going to help you get out of
that and you mix in there your wife's
medical issues and that puts an extra
strain on it but it does not break the
camel's back
uh so yeah you need to get on top of
this and and
you guys need to cut your freaking
lifestyles and stay out of restaurants
and you're not going on vacation until
you get some of this stuff straightened
up
but that's everybody that's not just you
wherever right
yeah we don't eat out just because my
wife can't okay you know
yeah that makes sense that makes sense
and but here's the thing when you have
this much physical pain
in the family chronic pain it begins to
affect
all decision making and that's what i
was going to aim to he
hit his we got like a sliver into his
life where
i'm going from job to job to job to job
man when
home is hard and someone that you love
is in pain and hurting
man it's easy to go chasing happiness
enjoyed other places well and
um you're looking for the one thing
that's right you're looking for a silver
bullet yeah i just i could just get that
one thing
if i could just get that one thing i'm
gonna try this i'm gonna try if i could
just get that one thing and and
and that's a normal thing and it's a
type of desperation and every time i get
desperate right after that i'm stupid
a hundred percent of them and so um
you know i think you settle in on this
job you look for some stuff you can do
at home after everybody's asleep
a lot of stuff and you make some extra
money and you tighten up this budget
and you begin to get your hands around
the emotional parts of managing through
this pain
as well as the financial parts and it'll
be the first time in your life and it's
time